[Music]
[Applause]
coming up next on booknotes we talk with
british historian martin gilbert author
[Music]
[Applause]
martin gilbert author of churchill alive
what's your favorite story about winston
churchill i have so many really but
there's always one for for each occasion
my favorite story is the cover you're
holding up this picture was suppressed
for 43 years
it was taken when churchill was in the
middle of the second world war
he was feeling confident that he just
won roosevelt's support for
the war effort in europe he'd gone up to
ottawa he'd won the canadian parliament
round and he was stopped by a
photographer in a corridor it took that
lovely picture and the photographer was
dissatisfied and when churchill put his
cigar in his mouth and started lighting
up the photographer grabbed the cigar
and got the famous frowning
disagreeable churchill who's graced
every postage stamp and every other book
cover
and for which millions incidentally have
been made in in photographic fees
and it's not the real churchill i mean
you know if i were to punch you in the
face and then take a picture whoever saw
you like that except me
and so
my favorite picture is this one and it's
the real churchill and the smiling
church how did you get it for the cover
i was promoting the english edition of
the book in canada in may and found that
on my floor of the hotel where the
publishers had put me was the studio of
this photographer by sheer chance i
didn't even know he was still alive so i
knocked on his door walked in there was
a ding like going into a haberdasher
shop
and i took it from there
my combination of charm
ingenuity i acquired the picture it's
interesting if you put an english
version of the book out it goes to
canada instead of the american version
going to canada
and i was pleased because it's it's the
real churchill and one of my aims in the
book was to get rid of all these
myths and carbuncles you know the
warmonger the disagreeable man the
imperialist with no vision so i thought
the cover should reflect that did you
spend much time around winston churchill
in 1961 which is exactly 30 years ago
when i was a young kid of 25
i was asked by his son to join a team
rather a chaotic team of people who were
trying to help randolph his son in
preparing this great multi-volume
biography
and that's where i really learned my my
trade i mean i was the one who had to go
through the original papers and bring
them to randolph my section of the
history
and there i was touching his letters
finding his school reports sometimes
even opening envelopes that had been
sealed in 1894 or 1895
and so in a way from then from that
moment for 30 years he was with me i
suppose every day of my life but i never
smoked a cigar what year did he die he
died in 1965 three years after i started
work for randolph and i was actually
over here then in in the states
and i had a wonderful discovery which
really gave me randall's confidence and
put even deeper into the churchill story
i went to the new york public library
and i knew that churchill had had a
friendship with an american tammany hall
boss in new york and i asked to see the
churchill file in that man's papers he
was called burke cochran
and they said oh we're terribly sorry we
only have the letters from the american
novelist winston churchill was such a
person and it was so cold outside that
day i said well all right let me look at
those and they turned out to be all the
letters from my winston church they'd
been misfiled
and they included a letter he'd written
from prison camp on his 25th birthday a
long fascinating letter so from that
moment randall thought i was a genius so
all it was it was misfiling and
and we went from strength to strength i
used to go from archive to archive me i
met all his old girlfriends the girls he
proposed to who turned him down
and the girls who wanted him to marry
them and who he'd turned down including
the girl who was so angry that
he didn't want to marry her
but she said you know winston all you
men are the same
you are absolutely rotten and you said
you're quite right you said
we're all worms but i do believe i am a
glow worms.
it's hard to be honest with you it's
hard to know where to start but let me
start with you
uh
have you been known as the official
biographer
i'm called the official biographer
though to the enormous credit of the
churchill family they never asked to see
a single word of what i was writing
until the books were printed and bound
and ready for sale to the public and
they never asked me to delete a word or
to skirt around a particular issue so
official is a misnomer if it's thought
to mean a censored or restricted
biographer what does it mean to be the
official man
it means some poor sod had to be willing
to give 30 years of his working life
give up his university teaching give up
his lecturing give up the amenities of
being as it were a clubable dawn on an
oxford university high table and be
willing to sit in archives which i i
enjoyed and i don't complain about one
moment but basically it meant you know
someone who would do it full time day
after day for 30 years
what part of winston churchill do you
enjoy
researching the most what i mean by that
is he was an artist he was an orator he
was a writer he was a statesman he was a
leader what what part
got your most most of your attention i i
think the thing which fascinated me most
was his work as a parliamentarian he
entered parliament in in 1900 he was
very young he was just 25 years old
and and he spent the next
55 years
in the parliament and he made that his
life and for example he wrote every
single one of his parliamentary speeches
nowadays it's quite rare as you know for
a leading figure to write his speeches
he might correct what is his speech
writers write
and he not only wrote them but he
rewrote them and he he worked on them
and it's a common misconception that he
just sort of used words in an airy fairy
way i mean the famous phrase by jeff
kennedy he mobilized english language
and sent it into battle was true but
he used language for argument to lead
the house of commons again and again
thousands of occasions
through a complicated and unpopular
argument you know he was arguing for
example something you've got here
in the united states since 1933 a
minimum wage which our government still
resists he presented that the british
parliament you know for an hour and a
half in great and careful detail so that
really is fascinating how did this man
take an unpopular cause and persuade a
basically often hostile house of commons
to accept that the rightness and logic
of it because he was never a dictator he
could never pound the table and say
we'll do it everything depended on the
votes of the house of commons and the
years he lived
from when to win he was born in 1874
and he died in 1965 so it was a long
life he passed his 90th birthday and his
fir the first president whom he met
was mckinley
and he fortunately also met mckinley's
vice president teddy roosevelt because
shortly after he met mckinley mckinley
was assassinated and raziel became
president
and he knew woodrow wilson well and had
many debates with him over whether
the bolsheviks should be contained by
the allies in 1918 or whether they
should be allowed to stew in their own
jews churchill believed that the
anti-bolshevik russians should be
assisted to overthrow bolshevism and
woodrow wilson declined
he knew
franklin roosevelt extremely well they
were the war leaders in world war ii
and he knew truman and greatly respected
truman he was in a way the encourager of
what became the truman doctrine
in foreign affairs he encouraged america
to emerge as a world leader
and eisenhower was
somebody with whom he had when
eisenhower's president a most incredible
conflict i mean it wasn't personally
violent but it was
almost disastrous for churchill
churchill wanted when stalin died to go
with eisenhower to moscow and meet
stalin's successors in moscow and say
right now we can end the cold war now we
can you know we are strong we have the
nuclear capacity
but we wish to be on good terms with you
we wish to help your economy in return
for you moderating your dictatorship he
said let's at least go to moscow and
eisenhower refused and very much
humiliated churchill
both uh to his to churchill's cabinet
and also in the international
discussions churchill never left it
alone for four years he kept coming back
to it pleading with ike
let us try and break the cold war but
you know it was the wrong time in
american politics and in the end it was
reagan and gorbachev and bush and
gorbachev
and thatcher and major who did what he
had pleaded with ike to do
you say 55 years did he spend all that
time in the parliament was he there all
those years he only had a year and a
half out of parliament
and that was in 1922 when he he had to
fight an election but he just had his
appendix out and he used to joke he said
at one stroke i lost my place in the
government my seat in parliament and my
appendix all three had gone but he came
back after a year and a half and even in
the famous wilderness years when there's
a misconception actually in america that
he was alone in fact there's even a book
come out i can't remember the author
which says
lion alone he was never alone in the
wilderness years he had an enormous
following in parliament
in the government circles in the civil
service and among the public who
realized that his warnings that hitler
did have to be confronted if war was to
be avoided it had to be told look thus
far no further
he was always in parliament during those
wilderness years so he always had you
know his place he was actually on the
front bench as you your viewers know
from the british parliament quite a
powerful place to be
and so
his was always a voice within the
parliamentary system he was never really
out of it and of course churchill out of
office was a man who went down to his
country house chartwell in kent
and had around him probably more cabinet
ministers and government officials than
sat around the cabinet table i mean he
was a magnet he was fun he was fun to be
with he was he was interesting he when
he was serious it was something worth
you know being present at and so people
flocked to him almost like moths to a
lamp
he married how many times
only once he was in love with a
beautiful girl whom he met in india and
went riding on elephants in his youth
around the city of hyderabad in southern
india but she uh somehow wasn't quite
for him
then he met a pretty girl and hardly
noticed her at dinner and at the end of
the dinner
he said i'm sorry i didn't talk to you
but i've written a book about my father
may i send it to you and she said yes
she rather liked him and she never heard
again from him that was a girl called
clementine they met four years later he
had forgotten the promise which he
hadn't given of sending the book and he
fell in love with her and proposed to
her
even then he was totally indecisive we
think of him as a man who knew what he
wanted and went how to get it he wanted
to marry her but he didn't know how to
do it and
he invited her to blenheim where his
family lived and they spent the weekend
together and his cousins noticed he
wasn't popping the question he wasn't
asking her on the final morning when she
was due to go to london he was lying in
bed and his cousin the duke went into
his bedroom and said winston you've got
to get out of bed he hated getting out
of bed in the morning you've got to get
out of bed and propose so finally he got
out he went into the garden he couldn't
bring himself to do it it came on to
rain the two of them went for shelter
into a little sort of ornamental temple
and there he finally said will you marry
me and she said yes and from that moment
he had nobody else in his life and she
was a wonderful woman not because she
was somehow just ornamental but as
you'll see from the book whenever she
felt he was going wrong whenever she
felt his character was perhaps
disintegrating a bit he was becoming a
little rough she would send him notes
beautifully written notes winston you're
not doing the right thing don't do this
and written with love but also with
great firmness so she was was more than
just an ornament really at his table
they were married for how long
they were married in 1908 and
when he died in
1965 they were they were still married
we had how many children had five
children one who died as a little child
of meningitis before she was three which
is a sad episode in their lives they had
a son randolph whom i worked for it was
wonderfully rambunctious and had a
wonderful family life
a church will belong to that generation
perhaps it's almost gone now who
believed that every the family should
always be there i mean if a prime
minister was coming to tea
or
secretary of state was coming to dinner
you had your family around the table and
you didn't inhibit the talk and indeed
if the family was young as churchill's
family were of course when they were
young
uh you had games you had a lovely game
which which you played the blue cat the
next person said the bright cat the next
one said the bold cat the brave cat you
tried to exhaust the adjectives
beginning with b and if there was a
sector of state or somebody there he
joined you know he was invited to join
in and uh in this way the children grew
up surrounded by by the most marvelous
politics and and humor and sometimes
they had awful rows and on one occasion
uh churchill was sort of laying down the
law about something and suddenly
randolph began to lay down the law and
churchill looked at him and said stop
interrupting me when i'm interrupting
but they enjoyed themselves and uh
animals were part of the
of the show there was lots of cats and
lots of dogs that i discovered he's
always thought of as the bulldog in
british history
and i discovered that when he was a
schoolboy at the age of 11
i put it in the book it was so nice he
sold his bicycle in order to have enough
money to buy a bulldog
there are some things direct american
connections his mother
his mother was born in brooklyn there
was a little plaque where she was born
in henry street she was raised in
rochester
and he always used to say himself i'm
half american
and holy british and his enemies said of
him you're half alien
and wholly reprehensible that was a
different catalyst
he once used his mother's american
connection to very powerful effect
he wanted in 1941
in the spring
to broadcast the american people to try
to explain from why britain was at war
and why sooner or later the united
states would find itself in this war
and clearly you know he couldn't do this
officially roosevelt you know couldn't
challenge the isolationist by such a
method or it would have been awful for
him politically
so the two of them arranged they were
great conspirators together in the
interests of democracy and defeating
tyranny
they arranged for president valentine
the university of rochester to invite
churchill to get an honourary degree
because it was where his mother grew up
and of course he couldn't come over in
the war with the battle atlantic so he
said as if outlaw i tell you what
president valentine why don't i
broadcast my acceptance speech well of
course once you're broadcasting across
the atlantic it can be picked up
everywhere from
new orleans to seattle and uh
from bangor to san diego and so he made
his wonderful broadcast to the americans
very understanding of the american
predicament not hectoring but saying you
know sooner or later
all good forces must confront the evil
forces
and when you do it you have to be
confident that you know why you're doing
it and you have to be very strong to
face the setbacks that will come on the
way our viewers when they watch the
british house of commons see a winston
churchill on the floor of the commons
today who is he
that is uh churchill's grandson and
indeed there is a nice american
connection there because his mother
pamela is mrs pamela harriman who lives
here in washington and was a churchill
side during the second world war
and there are some lovely stories in the
book which she recounts
she was often with him late at night
when
desperate military moves were imminent
and she was one of the people who
witnessed in the intimacy of his study
just how concerned he was
about the fate of those who were
inevitably going to die in these
assaults it wasn't for him again
or or or a statistic
he somehow felt
the plight of every soldier and and it
was because he had been a young soldier
his mother his american mother had been
given task after task by churchill
starting from the task get me to london
during queen victoria's jubilee in 1887
when he was 12. he didn't want to see
the queen he wanted to see buffalo bill
cody and annie oakley who were
performing at else court with 500
indians and god knows how many buffaloes
and he instructed his mother later get
me to the scene of action get me to
where the wars are instantly not to
fight he was a newspaper man and of
course a newspaper man it's no good you
know peter arnett sitting in the savoy
in london he has to be in baghdad and so
churchill was always saying to his uh
mother you know get me to the scene of
action and uh she did and this was her
sort of great role she was the the
pusher he once said of her very
disarmingly my mother left no stone
unturned she left no cutlet uncooked and
indeed she she really worked hard to
entertain on on his behalf
and so he saw war at first hand thanks
to his mother and he saw the cruelties
of war and he was always
saying to fellow politicians
the supreme object of statesmanship is
to stop war happening in fact i found
something he wrote which moved me very
greatly i put it in the book in 1900
after a battle which many british people
regard as a great victory in south
africa excited the flags went up
he wrote a piece about it a journalistic
piece he'd been at the battle but he
ended his peace
if
modern men of light and leading would
see the face of war more often
ordinary folk would see it hardly ever
you've got uh 100 and this is huge 266
pages in here but this is
the final is this going to be the final
this is it all in one volume from cradle
to grave
how many volumes have you written
i wrote
six of the eight volumes of the official
narrative
and i produced eight volumes of
documents his letters and documents in
fact i'm now doing his war documents but
this is everything
boiled down to one it's a sort of
hopefully a delicious consummate of
churchill's life
ever count the number of words you've
written about winston churchill i never
did but very much to my embarrassment
the guinness book of world records did
and they put it in as the longest
biography in english language but as i'm
not a believer that writing is has
quality because of length i'm most
slightly well not ashamed of it but it's
a bit bizarre it's about
eight and a half million words
but you know i started
with 15 tons weight of his letters and
papers
so
you know it had to be constantly reduced
and sifted through
and i used to even read his laundry list
and uh people said what can you possibly
learn from a laundry list you certainly
can't publish laundromats
but on one occasion i found a laundry
list from beirut from a beirut hotel and
i thought myself i did i didn't know
when church was in beirut and from that
laundry list it had a date
i discovered a journey which was not as
it were in the history books which he'd
made to the middle east to beirut and
then to amman and then to jerusalem and
then i found british officials young
rich officials at the time who had been
there that year 1934 and even then
acquired some historical documents about
his views and thoughts during that visit
so laundry lists have their uses too
where did you grow up
i was born in london
and my parents were londoners
and when i was two and a half the the
war began and my father was doing war
work he was doing night work
and so when i was three and a half i was
put on a ship with hundreds of other
kids
without my parents and sent to canada
and churchill instead had been against
this he regarded as a sort of scuttle
and when one of the ships was sunk and
children drowned many children drowned
he stopped it so i was there with about
four thousand other kids in canada
and i discovered when i was writing this
book that in 1944
just at the time of the normally
landings churchill saw that the
mauritania great ocean liner which had
been converted to a troop ship
was in new york
anchored in hudson
and uh
there were only three thousand troops
going back on it to britain because of
course the american force is already
over there so he said why not bring the
children back
from canada so telegrams were sent and i
was among the children who was rounded
up i was put on a train by myself in
toronto station
one of the most vivid memories of my
life is arriving i was then seven and a
quarter grand central station with a
label around my neck grand central and
it still looks a big big station but
then for a little boy it was very big
and there were a lot i remember the
great sort of lines and soldiers and
enormous crowd and i waited patiently i
don't think i cried and finally someone
came and said little boy come with me it
was a hot june day in 44 and i was led
to the docks i went back the other day
for yesterday to see the the pier where
we embarked
and then i found in churchill's papers a
little note
where he put against the mauritania's
story the mauritania file
make sure there are enough lifeboats on
board for the extra children
now that's interesting this man who then
was having to
defeat hitler in normandy counter the
flying bomb
deal with the whole problem of defeating
japan still remember the extra kids on
the ship better make sure there are
enough
lifeboats in case the ship goes down
where'd you go to school
i went to school at highgate which is a
private school in london
when the war was over
my father brought me back to london he'd
been evacuated himself to north wales
and suddenly it was the first day of the
school term and dad had made no
arrangements i mean he'd been involved
in the war you know many people were in
that boat so he put me in a car of a
friend
and we drove around london until he
found a school which had a place
for one little boy
it was a boarding school i was then
eight and a half
and i went to that school from 1945 till
1954 and then i went into the british
army
and
when i finished my
military duties my military service
i went up to university
so i was somehow a border all my life i
was at boarding school in the army of
course you're you're in your barracks
and at oxford you're very pleasantly
in uh you know students lodgings at
oxford
and finally i graduated in 1960 and a
year later randolph churchill said join
my team
do you have any reason to know why he
did i mean was there some specific
thing that caught his attention when it
came to you yes immediately after i
graduated i i wrote a book with with my
very first pupil uh marvel's person
called richard gott who later became a
distinguished journalist on the guardian
and we wrote a book called the appeasers
together we were very excited by it we
were young historians exposing somehow
neville chamberlain's not just his
desire to postpone war but it is his
desire to get on good terms with hitler
and we found a lot out about that and
one of randolph's friends read it and
she said to randolph you really ought to
get this young man and talk to him she
used a lovely phrase in her letter which
he showed me he is full of zeal to set
history right
and anyway he started sending me
telegrams and i'd heard of him only as a
terrible drunk and right-wing sort of
fascist beast you know the portrayal of
students of those days
but finally the the head of my college
who had actually been churchill's
research assistant in the 30s 40s and
50s
said to me you know why don't you go
you'll have an amusing evening you'll
have a lot of stories to dine out on
and you know you'll come back the next
morning
well i went
i had an amusing and amazing evening
and the next morning instead of coming
back randolph said to me will you join
my team
and i joined it i thought i'd last four
or five months i lasted five years
he died i thought i'd write the
biography what was left to be done in
five or six years
and i finished it the multi-volume three
years ago were you around him when he
died
well i was actually on holiday when he
died the whole thing was very
distressing because
in his last months
roundup was not well but he he had a
wonderful brain i had a lot of respect
for randolph he loved history he was
full of zeal for setting it right you're
talking about the sun sound right and
and he once said to me you know martin
i'm not interested in whitewashing my
father i'm interested in the truth and
he was there was such a thing as
historical truth for him and indeed i
hope for me
and uh
in the last year of his life the kennedy
family asked him to write the biography
of of j f kennedy and he was very very
understandably flattered by that and
moved by that
and so as well as continuing the
biography in the last year with the
church of biography he became like
distracted by the challenge of kennedy i
mean he intended to finish churchill
first on the other hand he couldn't
quite bring himself not to sort of begin
thinking about the kennedy
and uh robert kennedy was the member of
the family who had really sort of uh
asked him to do it in fact i i listened
in it was my job to listen into the
phone conversation when robert kennedy
asked him and then robert kennedy was
assassinated and randolph died within
24 hours of each other 1968 68 and
suddenly the whole
pack of cards collapsed it was a great
tragedy
and uh but i i respected randolph
churchill he wanted to tell his father's
story and when all when i was writing my
volumes and particularly i was writing
this volume i always thought you know
not only would winston churchill you
know sort of feel i was doing it
properly but would randolph the
churchill field when people say to me oh
he was just an alcoholic there's a new
book out
about him as an alcoholic and the whole
churchill family is drinker i think well
you know with me we had many long days
and nights when you know his mind was
crystal clear and history was what we
were doing and getting his father's
story right was what we were about and
he told lovely stories about his father
some of which i was able to put in my
book you know when he told his stories
he used to
if i would laugh he'd say that's for my
book not your book and of course paul
randolph died and the stories ended up
in my book
is there such a thing that's built up
over the years as a martin gilbert
inc in other words where have you got a
big force behind you that helps you do
research and secretary of state i've
always believed in doing it oneself i've
always done all my own research i i was
very lucky indeed
that i always had one person to help me
you know sort the files and go with me
to the archives
if only because under the british system
one person can only call for three files
but two people can call for six
and uh one of my assistants larry ahn is
now running a policy study unit in
claremont in california he was extremely
good but unfortunately fell in love with
my secretary so he married her and she's
also in california and then i got
another assistant who came and uh this
was in 1971 and i fell in love with her
so she is now my wife and in fact she
has been ever since my we sit together
and we read every document together and
i then write the chapter and she then
reads it and says wait a minute
you haven't properly interpreted that
document or you haven't got the best out
of it or you've exaggerated what it says
so it's been the two of us
and the whole biography i wrote in pen
and ink in fact i
this is the pen i wrote the eighth
volume with i was a pen and ink man and
then my wife said
for this one volume we have to become
modern creatures i just want to i want
to
see what kind of pen is this it's called
a pelican it's a serviceable english
british pen
i think it may be french i'm not sure i
bought in san francisco
you wrote the entire eighth volume yes
with that pen right
and then i bought another pen to write
this volume with and my i said put it
away
we have to become modern and so i
acquired a
computer
and i wrote this on computer and i must
i enjoyed it enormously
though i did at one point put in a tease
which i forgot to eliminate off from the
disc
but it's not in the american edition
the british edition has it but i deleted
it for the american edition
uh this
volume cost 35
do you have any idea as as we sit here
how many these things you'll sell
i i believe that about 35 000 have sold
it came out on the first of november so
it's had what a almost a month run three
four weeks around
and it's now
in it's the second reprint is out and
hopefully third fourth fifth reprint if
your viewers all rush to buy it
i i would guess it has a hopefully it'll
go on selling because it is the one the
sole one volume work which contains his
his most personal stories most personal
letters
and uh everybody said you'll never do it
in one word you know there are many
multi-volumes mostly incomplete but you
know many people have tried a
multi-volume including myself
and you know the average man in the
street can't carry around an eight
volume or even a three volume set of a
bar can you buy the eight volume set at
one stop you can actually and it's now
come out in england in paperback so it's
even physically much more manageable but
you know my idea was a one volume you
know we live in an age where you know
much as one would like to sit down and
read books i mean even i just bought
today carlisle's history of the french
revolution in georgetown in an abridged
version because i wanted to re-read it
and i thought you know i ought to read
the three volumes but you can't so
here's churchill in one volume he fits i
mean
you know there's more to say but there's
so much there that you know uh it's it's
you know i sometimes go on holiday to a
village in the vo clues
and the nearest town is called apt in
southern france and there they have a
cake called an aptian when you're really
feeling a bit peckish and it's a
sort of fruitcake which only has fruit
if you know what i mean there's a bit of
cake and a lot of fruit anyway i like to
feel this is the book
fruity book one one more question on the
eighth volume uh how much would it cost
today if you bought all eight volumes
and can you buy it hard back or is it
just paperback uh you can get it in
hardback and get it in paper in
paperback the whole thing
would be about uh
well eight times to eighty pounds was
that about uh hundred dollars hundred
and twenty dollars more than that
100 50 right yes 150 the hardback uh
eight volumes would be more like 220 230
if winston churchill were alive today
and lived in this country and had to
join an american political party
any idea what he'd be
based on what he thought what he would
carry well he he he had belonged to both
the equivalent of the democrat and
republican parties you've been a liberal
and a conservative how many years in
each party about the same 20 very active
years as a liberal and a reformer and a
social reformer and a minimum wage man
at what point in his life
from the age of 30 to 50.
so he started off as a conservative in
the house he was briefly conservative
but hated the the then class-ridden
nature of the conservative party and
also he hated its aggressive imperialism
so he joined the liberals he became a
great pioneer
of social reform he introduced widows
pensions orphans pensions he introduced
the whole system of
fair deal at the workplace you know
a break for meals for people in
enterprises he believed that everybody
in their workplace the cameraman behind
your cameras should have a share in the
profit of the company so he was in that
sense of radical
and then he became a conservative in
1924 when he was already 50.
and uh as a conservative was a very good
conservative because he believed
in the defense of the realm of something
paramount and he he believed in not
grovelling to dictators and not giving
in to bullying internationally but he
wanted what his father had called tory
democracy a conservatism with a
genuinely classless face it's
interesting that john major our new
and in my view excellent uh conservative
prime minister has spoken of his desire
to establish a classless society which
was really what churchill was struggling
for
as to the parties he always said i've
belonged to both political parties and
then he'd say with a smile and i've
despised them both equally you see and
my guess is he he would join one of the
two american parties and try to change
it he would try to change it in the
direction he wanted
he he had enormous i mean i've looked at
you know the democrat and republican
programs and he had enormous sympathy
for for things in both of them
which essentially i mean he he felt the
supreme goal of statementship was
in international affairs to preserve
peace
but not at all costs and others preserve
peace unless the tyranny or the threat
was such that it had to be confronted
and had to be defeated and at home to
maintain the genuine unity of the nation
that's to say there should be nobody
whether it was race or economic
situation or creed nobody who had an
inferior position in the society and i
know my welfare handouts he believed in
free enterprise but that the poorest
person should have the opportunity to
avail itself of what free enterprise
could provide a person and for that
reason you know he even when he was in
charge of the prisons as home sector i
think that would be secretary of the
interior here he uh
he fought very hard to give prisoners
people were convicted criminals
the
the same opportunities once they were
released from prison to rise in society
and indeed he introduced programs in
prisons to enable them when they came
out to as he put it
establish themselves quickly in the
world of industry and you know to be
rehabilitated he even abolished the
system whereby the police controlled
prisoners once they were released and
introduced what we call the probation
system where an independent probation
service a non-police service supervises
prisoners and instantly it was robert
kennedy
who became very interested in in
churchill's philosophy of the rights of
even a convicted criminal against the
state in other words you couldn't push
any group of society down and say we're
not interested in you
and he fought very hard for example for
those who are disabled at work he
believed the state had some sort of
obligation should make some contribution
to people like that
to enable them to to lead a decent life
the other thing which i think is
going to be a feature of current
politics and either the democrats or the
republicans can grasp it it's up to you
know their political genius
he believed that at some point the
emphasis in industrial societies must
move from hours of work
which in his day he progressively
reduced you know you made the hours of
work less onerous less long
that the shift should be from hours of
work to hours of leisure
that in the end the state must concern
itself with
the ability of people to to use and
exploit their leisure time the
facilities should be provided that's why
when somebody once asked him in world
war ii
you know where do you want where do you
want your statue to go
when you're dead the great war leader he
said i don't really want a statue
i would like there to be parks in areas
where people have no parks so that those
people whose leisure time cannot include
walking in a park
will have a park
and it's interesting that when he died
and there was a move to set up his
statue the one that's in parliament
square now his widow clementine wrote to
the london times pointing out this that
her husband actually had not wanted
statues but parks
eight cabinet positions in his life
yes he entered the british cabinet
in uh well a long time ago in 1908
when he was still in his mid-thirties
and
he was lost in the cabinet in 1955. in
fact i was very interested to discover
quite by chance i i met
all the members of his final cabinet
and they recall all the ones who are
still alive which was the majority
and i knew anthony eden and harold
mcmillan and they both helped me
enormously with my work and some of
their recollections are there
and one of them said you know we were we
all said goodbye to him and it was the
day before his his official retirement
from public life
and he said there are two things i'd
like to say to you
he said first of all always remember
that man is spirit
and second he said
never be separated from the americans
now
he didn't make a great rhetorical
flourish just these two little points
man is spirit which he always believed
you always believed man had the capacity
for self-improvement he was always an
optimist in the ultimate evolution of
human destiny
and never be separated from the
americans the intensely practical you
know we are no longer a world power
we're not a superpower
we in the americans share common ideals
common heritage common goals
stick to them
and he believed that i found a letter
which he wrote
in 1916. he's always a man of foresight
in which he said
from now on you know after the united
states had come into world war one but
had not yet sent its troops over and he
knew that until the american troops came
there could be no victory over germany
on the western front
and he wrote 916 you know everything now
the future of the world depends on the
united states
the fact that she's a democracy the fact
that she is you know basically a decent
country that she doesn't intend to
dominate others that is the way the
world will go forward in the 20th
century and we must make sure we're
associated with them not only so that we
can be protected or get rich but because
this is the side we're on
he was prime minister how many times and
from what years he was prime minister
twice
he he was first of all prime minister of
1940 1945
1940 the government had basically tried
to pursue a war on a party basis
a conservative party which was in power
running the war
and this was not satisfactory to to the
british people and it was not good for
the conduct of the war and there was a
great demand from the labour party that
they should have a place
and generally from people of no party
that you know the war should be seen to
be united effort at the top
because after all the workers were
having to work 24 hours a day shifts you
know multiple ships
and
so he became prime minister of an
all-party government and and that was
his finest hour really and and one of
the things i show in the book was his
he needed inaudible his sphere of war
administration he knows ernest bevin who
was a labor man of distinction and and
he was made minister of labor was given
somehow a free reign
to organize the labor aspect because
church was never an anti-union man that
was an interesting aspect but still he
brought in all parties and he brought
him professionals
and then in 1945 when the war was ending
the british public said let's go back to
party politics and to hell with the
conservative party who betrayed us
before the war and of course churchill
had been one of those who had always
cried out the conservatives are
betraying us before the war not standing
up to hitler not rearming the nation not
getting on good terms of the united
states so he played his part in his own
defeat in 1945 because people gave a
thumbs down to the conservatives but he
then became leader of the party uh
leader of the opposition
and he rebuilt the conservative party he
brought in young men like harold
macmillan who was later prime minister
and r.a butler who was later chancellix
czecho the head of the treasury
and he gave them great authorities for
example he gave macmillan the brief of
devising a housing policy not unlike uh
jack kemp's present housing policy you
know you must build houses and uh on a
scale which is commensurate with the
needs
and so the the public responded to this
they saw that the old churchill had
somehow created a new
party
and
they voted him back in and he became
prime minister for the second time in
1951
and he remained prime minister through
his 80th birthday for another four and a
half years till 1955
and one nice thing is that when he
retired he said i'm not going to
interfere
my successors have had their training
they've got their opportunity
and although he's always thought of as
some sort of interfering
person
he he left them alone and at the time of
the serious crisis when
anton eden his successor went to war
with egypt and as you know the united
states uh opposed britain's action
churchill had certain views
and he didn't want to make them public
he didn't want to embarrass eden
so he set off in his motor car from his
little country house about four hours
drive from where eden was at that time
and halfway he pulled into a lay by
and dictated to his secretary a little
note just a page
drove on to eden's residence left it
you know at the door
and return back another four hours drive
a week doesn't go by in this country
where some politicians somebody making a
speech somewhere quotes winston
churchill
as saying
something to the effect uh it was
winston churchill that said democracy is
the worst form of government except for
every other form or something i mean and
people are always
doing something with that what was the
real story that's what he said of course
what i i i share mario cuomo's view
that
everything has to be taken in context
i've been following this debate where
the cuomo should declare himself or not
and one of the papers quoted him as
saying it was exactly 30 days ago and i
began my
trip tried to help my book on its way
and and and he said everything has to
put in his context as we weighed and
studied in its context and i understood
exactly what he meant because what
churchill was really saying was
you are flirting with fascism you are
flirting with communism
another one is flirting with some
extreme right or extreme left view
but when all said and done democracy for
all its faults is the only way forward
and he believed this you know as i said
you asked me you know earlier his life
was spent in parliament and he was
always prepared to first of all bow to
the wishes of parliament
and uh to argue his case very carefully
before parliament and you know he one of
the things that comes out in the book is
that
he
he
he had enormous
numbers of enemies enormous setbacks
it's not a study in failure because i
don't believe church was a failure and
certainly his ideas weren't failures but
it was just it's a study in setbacks and
blows i mean not only the physical blood
he was squashed flat on 5th avenue and
86th street 931 i mean
almost into a pancake and nobody thought
he would survive
but the blows of defeat the blows of of
parliament turning against him the blows
of of the government refusing to follow
his lead and his incredible resilience
in bouncing back so it's one of the
features of the book that even as a
school kid he was being accused of
things which he hadn't done and was
having to defend himself and uh recently
i i read in the paper that uh vice
president quail was being accused of
some involvement in in in in drugs and
drug trafficking and i wanted to write
him and say look don't take it
tragically when churchill was 20
and a young soldier he was accused of
buggering
and you know that's
you know a terrible accusation well he
ended up prime minister it just took
quite a long time why was he accused of
buggering what is it
you don't know what bakery is
define it please no deal
sorry i thought the word
bugger is what used to be called uh the
an unnatural act of the oscar wilde type
is how it was actually phrased in the
euphemism of the british papers
it's uh
you don't know what buggeries and when
was it
it's a very nasty thing which men do to
each other
he was accused by a fellow cadet at
sandhurst who had a grievance against
churchill churchill was very successful
he was a very successful map maker he's
a very successful horse rider
and somehow you know this young man
he understood that if you make an
accusation against winston churchill the
even the 20 year old energetic ambitious
appearing everywhere views on everything
a nasty accusation
could stick enough people would say hmm
perhaps there's something to it
perhaps this man is a deviant perhaps he
is a bugger and
churchill had to bring a libel action
which he won and it was the first of i
suppose 30 libel actions in his career
which he had to bring against this sort
of charge you know he once escaped from
a prisoner of war camp in south africa
as a young man
got over the wall
and his political enemies said ah he
didn't really escape
he had given his parole
and he had promised you know that he
would behave and he was going to be let
out and then just as a show off knowing
that he was going to be let out he broke
his parole and jumped over the wall and
and this was untrue and i went to south
africa and i found the actual prison
authority's correspondence which it's
clear that they refused to give him any
special treatment that they said he will
be held here even more
carefully guarded than the other
prisoners because he's a troublemaker
he'll he'll write about the war and so
on
and he really did have to jump over the
wall and had a very extraordinary series
of
very narrow escapes with death before he
got back to england and of course as an
escapee he was a hero and that's what
propelled him into parliament a young
man who had jumped over the wall
you told us when we started this that
this picture was new
and that you found it in canada
right
anything else new about this in this
volume stuff that uh you didn't have in
your other eight
do you know there's probably something
new on every page it was my it was my
ambition that you would open the book
anywhere and read a page and say halfway
down
i never knew that
that is new
and oh there all sorts of things all
sorts of uh i mean like the letter which
he wrote
when he escaped from the prisoner of war
camp which he left under his pillow
and the grandson of the commandant the
prison commandant gave it to me in
pretoria came to see me door and said by
the way
we have this letter and so it it's
full of lovely new things and uh
full of little aspects of uh history
which perhaps have been neglected and
forgotten and also his humor
and his
his all-roundness you mentioned his
painting i mean he
he he wasn't an obsessive man about
politics he was obsessive about right
and wrong
but right and wrong in the wider sense
even fairness you know in the family he
he made sure for example that when he
went abroad to his conferences if one
child went to one if randolph went to
one then he'd ask his daughter sarah to
another is specifically fair he he hated
anything which smacked of unfairness of
social unfairness political unfairness
and of course international unfairness
the evil of totalitarianism that was his
great
enemy and he never compromised with evil
though he understood
that sometimes your country could be so
weak that there was nothing you could do
and uh you had to see things which you
believed in
blotted out that's what happened of
course at the altar conference where he
fought so hard and incidentally
roosevelt
did not uh
betray the democracies that some
americans have been taught
both in a way and their staffs fought so
hard
for a democratic poland but the red army
had already occupied poland and there
was no way in which they could make war
on stalin
and therefore you know the fate accompli
was there what i found and put in this
book was that churchill wanted to hold
the altar conference before the red army
had overrun eastern europe when you
still could have some sort of argument
and bargaining and of course you still
had your armies to direct in particular
directions
and
he proposed of course the altar
was something that came up later he
proposed jerusalem as the site of the
conference why because roosevelt who
could only travel by ship
could go all the way to haifa port
on the quincy
and because stalin who would only travel
by train could go from moscow to
jerusalem by train in those days and
churchill even sent him the railway
route and as it were the timetable and
churchill who was older and sicker than
both of them in a curious way would fly
but uh
they turned down the jerusalem
conference darling said he didn't want
to leave russia and residents said he
couldn't leave the united states because
of course he had
uh the elections coming up october was
very close to november and it may be
that the jerusalem conference would have
done what yalta couldn't do but the ifs
of history are not for me therefore the
novelist who comes along afterwards
anything about him you didn't like
well you know i wasn't in the business
of of like and dislike uh sometimes i
read things of his which i felt oh dear
you know
i wouldn't have said that or i wouldn't
have done that and sometimes i read
things i said goodness me
how wise how extraordinary but i felt my
job wasn't to impose that judgment on
the reader i had to say to the reader to
you this is what he really stood for
this is what he really did what he
really said
you may like it or you may not like it i
mean one very uh
clear example
he believed that britain should
relinquish
southern ireland catholic ireland and
establish and he negotiated he
established himself
uh the irish free state he brought in
the is free state bill an independent
catholic government in dublin which
exists to this day
now many british conservatives regarded
that as the thin end of the wedge you
know this was the heartland of the
british empire
you know to give up dublin
you know what will he give up next
windsor castle
so you know if you were a a british
conservative with that perspective on
ireland you would find that a very
distressing chapter
and many
people who for example
he wanted the jews to have a national
home in a state
and he believed that arrangements should
be made so that the jews could become a
majority even if arabs had to become a
minority and for that reason persuaded
roosevelt to exclude palestine from the
terms of the atlantic charter which
would have given one man one vote in
1945 and meant an arab majority and he
said no i'm committed to a jewish
majority in palestine now many people
find that offensive and even racist
in fact i even read one american
biography called him racist because of
this sort of attitude
but that's for you to decide i mean
it'll depend on your perspective and
your
your view of events
was he an interferer i mean that's
something which you know people say well
it's very distressing how he interfered
then i found an example of his
interference
in 1921 he said to the british
government in baghdad
we ought to establish an independent
homeland for the kurds in northern iraq
because one day
a government in iraq might come to being
which will persecute the kurds well his
advisor said this is interference you
know this is what a biographer will say
you know look at that bad news
and they wrote him a letter and they
said we're not prepared to do this
because britain will always be able to
exercise a restraining influence in
baghdad
well they were wrong we now know they
were wrong but if you were reading it
from the perspective of a civil servant
an administrator it would be one more
example of this unpleasant feature of
always interfering always knowing better
he literally 90.
he smokes cigars every day
well he lit cigars every day he didn't
always smells
did he drink a lot
in moderation he drank he like he'd like
nice wines and good wines
i can strongly recommend you some of the
wines he liked
but uh if you were to drink
his whiskey and water you would say why
hasn't someone put some whiskey in this
water
did he eat a lot of red meat
constantly he loved red meat
well
on one occasion when when he was
when he was coming from
ottawa to to to to to washington he was
served an enormous american
stake on the train
he said i i
i'm not a cannibal he couldn't
understand you know so much with me but
he loved food he was a great uh eater he
could sometimes eat a whole roast
chicken for breakfast
he had an insatiable appetite he loved
good food
he loved what he called an important
pudding
if he was given a dessert which
was nothing much to it he'd say this
pudding has no theme he liked it to be
important he had a voracious appetite
and he uh you know he he enjoyed every
aspect of life to the full he he had a
lot
yes he was a good sleeper he read an
enormous amount you know he's almost the
only person i've come across
i don't know what the president united
states does it's interesting to know
but
before he went to bed
he arranged for all the newspapers which
of course were published in our country
about midnight to be to get all the
newspapers and he read all the
newspapers he didn't just read you know
the london tie he read the times and the
guardian news chronicles and the popular
papers in the math circulation paper and
even the communist paper he only cut out
the communist paper when he was so hard
up
that uh his wife said darling we must
cut down on the papers we haven't got
enough money and then he reluctantly
took out the communist paper and one or
two others but he read all the papers
and he read them and he absorbed them
and anything in them that he found that
smacked of that he didn't like or that
caught some sparkles imagination he
would follow it up he would call in a
shorthand writer and dictate something
and uh even ministers were often
surprised in the morning to get a minute
from him saying i see in the papers that
you know your department has done this
or that and plea pray tell me why he
said pray tell me this peter and they
were known as his prayers
and god helped the minister who didn't
have an answer or couldn't find somebody
to give an answer
was he faithful to his wife
he was absolutely faithful to he adored
his wife and he uh
he was a very he was faithful he was
very honest man
he
he had very high moral standards
and people understood that and i i found
and i told the story once or twice in
the book that when other ministers even
of the opposition party
were in some trouble of the sort
nowadays that of course would make the
headlines sexual or financial
they would go to him
they knew that he would somehow give
them good and disinterested advice and
would be totally discreet and never tell
anybody that
now that's an extraordinary thing no you
know i i've always felt that tells you
something of his qualities because it's
not you know winston churchill
the war leader and the monolith and
and the man with the frown it's a man to
whom people who are even his opponents
went
for advice and guidance he was a very
good guide and he he had various sort of
you know
little standard things if someone came
said i don't know whether to do this or
not
this example that's what i should not
mention in the cuomo context but he used
to say when you're in doubt as to
whether to lay an egg or not don't
in other words you know if something is
really bugging you you're not sure
whether you should do it or not don't do
it and he had these various sort of
little rules of thumb
last question what is martin gilbert
going to do for the rest of his life
well martin gilbert i know him quite
well he's got a few ideas uh he's going
to finish churchill's wartime documents
which will be a five volume set
and then he's embarking upon a three
volume history of the 20th century and
he hopes that'll see him out to the end
of the century
this is what the book looks like it's
called churchill a life by his official
biographer martin gilbert thank you very
much for joining us thank you
join us next week on booknotes when our
guest will be new york newsday columnist
jimmy breslin author of damon runyon a
life
that's next sunday at eight and eleven
pm eastern time
for a transcript of tonight's book notes
program send five dollars to c-span
transcripts in care of tape writer
incorporated post office box 885 in
lincolnshire illinois the zip code is
60069
coming up next it's this week's question
time from the british house of commons
[Music]